if we are serious about preventing
climate change we need to be pumping a
lot less of this into the atmosphere
that is the message of a new UN report
its authors one of a growing gap between
rising emissions and the reductions
needed to achieve the goals set out in
the Paris climate Accords emissions have
to be cut by a quarter by 2030 to keep
global warming at 2 degrees Celsius and
avoid drastic consequences says the
report
and the biggest elephant in the room
that we refused to see is the risk that
it poses to everything we like and
appreciate in this planet whether you
biodiversity is your thing or
sustainable finance or you know the the
health of the planet and the people or
prosperity or peace or human movements I
mean users pick up anything you like
everything is at risk at a UN summit in
the Polish mining town of Katowice
starting Sunday delegates will hammer
out a plan to meet the Paris Accords a
toss that now seems much harder than
they first imagined and for more now on
that climate report that we heard about
there is one of the reports lead authors
it's dr. and all HOF she's head of the
climate resilience program at Technical
University of Denmark and she joins us
from Paris good morning doctor all half
your report finds that the gap between
greenhouse gas emissions and global
targets to limit those emissions is
wider than ever now what does that tell
you about our efforts to combat climate
change well it tells us that these
efforts are not you know at least and it
tells us that action is not happening at
the pace and it should be now your
report reveals that greenhouse gas
emissions have risen for the first time
in four years it's not just that there's
a huge gap that that we're actually
seeing more co2 coming out now can you
tell us what's behind that rise yes we
saw an increase in co2 growth at the
global level in 2017 following a period
of the three years where there'd been
stabilization of these and of course
that sparked the hope that we might be
seeing the beginning of the peak of
global emissions and some of the main
drivers for this rice were actually
stronger growth economic growth globally
and also slower declines in energy
intensity and especially
in carbon intensity now we're talking
about emissions there but of course it
emissions imply also temperature rise
and and that's what we're we're afraid
of it and the scientists like yourself
tell us that on current trans
temperatures could rise roughly 4
degrees Celsius by the end of the
century what sort of consequences would
that have our report says that if if one
who's in the current national climate
plans is implemented we would be looking
at three to three point two degrees
global warming and towards the end of
the century and it would have
devastating effects and it's important
to remember that these global our global
averages they hide a lot of differences
between continents and countries and
also they imply a huge increase in in
the extreme events and the variability
of climate change that we already see it
would have devastating consequences and
especially on areas and populations that
are already very vulnerable so it's
really not our world we want to pass on
to our children and grandchildren
dr. Olaf thank you very much for talking
with us that was dr. an all Hoffa lead
author of the UN emissions gap report
thank you